okay welcome everybody this afternoon to
the the third of this lecture series by
John Donne
under the general child beyond the
democratic maze we heard last week about
diagnosing democracy's power and then
understanding democracy's assent and
were left with the puzzle that democracy
in many ways is an idea with world
historical force but when you try to pin
down just what that world historical
force consists in and what its
consequences are as Professor Dunn has
shown us it's it's an extremely elusive
beast and today he is going to I think
start showing us just why it is so
elusive and as a prelude to putting our
understanding on of democracy onto a
better footing in tomorrow's lecture so
today's lecture is called recognizing
democracy's disorientation and that as I
said is a prelude to his recovering our
bearings lecture that will take place
the same time tomorrow so professor Don
thank you very much yes I I tried to
show last week a little about how and
why a political idea which virtually no
one thought a good idea 250 years ago
and which survived principally as a
cautionary tale about a keenly resented
political experience ever longer ago
should have come to shape so much
imaginatively about the world we now
live in I'm starting off today from an
intriguing and very consequential
standoff between two constituents of
that world at the end of my second
lecture last week I tried to bring into
focus the key elements of a momentous
Internet
political confrontation on one side the
United States it's a view of how
governmental power can and should be
built authorized and directed across the
countries of the world called it
democracy
along with a relaxed confidence that
that view corresponds in very large
measure to the way in which power has in
fact been built or thighs and directed
within its own territories and for its
own people for an enviable long time
what that view highlights is the
authorizing potential of a process of
electoral competition operating within a
distinctive structure of inhibition and
delay the resulting model is very far
from transparent and it's operated in
very different ways over time what is
clear is that it costs very little light
on how the power of the American State
was in fact built or the wealth of the
American people has been created and
virtually none on how any other as yet
less fortunate population can reasonably
hope to build the power of their state
let alone augment their personal and
collective wealth on the other side of
the confrontation China there is a
rueful awareness of how governmental
power was in fact built in its own case
a more comforting sense of how
effectively that power has by now been
directed for a good three decades and of
the massive increments in wealth and
military and diplomatic potency which
have flowed from that direction and
altogether more discomforting sense of
the flimsiness of its authorization by
anything prior to and independent of
that all too recent success
for a very long time in face of the rest
of the globe the United States has
reveled in its own wealth and power it
has felt no need to go in quest of
either the position of China's rulers
could scarcely be more different the
authorization they now enjoy issues
overwhelmingly from the spectacular
scale of their all to recent success in
finding and securing both with the
United States prosperity power and
authorization have gone hand in hand and
done so almost from its outset many of
its local ideologues are still strongly
tempted to attribute its power to its
prosperity and each in turn to the
Felicity of its secular authorization
but no minimally informed interpreter of
China's experience could conceivably see
it that way in China authorization
remains a dimension of real jeopardy for
the regime as a whole many assume with
varying assurance that that conspicuous
jeopardy is sure to prove
inconsequential in practice and if it
does prove sir
if economic momentum that its current
velocity will authorize anything and
might run on forever
China's encounters with democracy as a
word or an idea might prove to carry no
residual political significance the
Communist Party's invocation of Lenin's
intellectual aftermath however
anachronistic at other latitudes and
however jejune in rational content may
continue to endow it with all the
authorization it requires but it's still
far from clear that that judgment is
going to prove right authorization by
momentum alone is notably hazardous for
any regime as soon as the momentum
falters the more squalid and brute
or aspects of the basis on which it is
being sustained come into sharper focus
and the appeal to other bases of
identification becomes costly Oh to
dispense with under their circumstances
authorization in by process gains
sharply in appeal and even a term like
democracy successfully neutered by
decades of all but vacuous utilization
may alter brutally in valency there have
been leading Chinese thinkers some of
them closely influenced by the eminently
American figure of John Dewey who have
seen democracy in essentially American
understanding as a recipe for China's
political future but they've not on the
whole been lucky in their dealings with
political power you could I suppose save
much the same Dewey himself the
attractions of Dewey's vision of
democracy are above all its picture of a
society flourishing through the active
exertion an interactive intellectual
energy of all its participants a society
surging with life and intelligence and
constantly assailing the practical
problems which come its way with all the
human resources to hand that picture
assumes the society to be there in the
first place and there as a society an
assemblage of human beings already
capable of recognizing one another
social membership and acting with
as well as against one another it
assumes a potential order not grounded
on the coercion of some by others and it
assumes that what is there independently
of coercion isn't just the state of
nature the Chinese picture in all its
historical heterogeneity assumes
something very different it assumes that
for order to be present in human life
requires its intellectual recognition
and the shaping and persuasive action of
is capable of that recognition it
assumes the need to teach the principles
of order to those without the personal
discernment to recognize them for
themselves and the need to convey to
those who cannot be trusted to do the
discerning for themselves the imperative
to accept it's been done for them by
those who emphatically can if the
American vision of justified Authority
is horizontal and heuristic its Chinese
counterpart with all due variation over
the bewilderingly long time over which
it has been deployed is hierarchical and
didactic it assumes the need for and the
potential availability of a definite
apex of authority and one which can and
should force its superior insight on the
rest of their fellow Chinese and still
more over the last two centuries on
those of their fellow citizens with the
biological misfortune not to be borne
harmed
it's very difficult to think across
those two spaces with any clarity and
see how each bears on the other it's
also lethally prejudicial to the very
attempt to do so to assume that either
of space offers a privileged perspective
from which to make that attempt the
single most important point about the
significance of democracy's Odyssey as a
political formula that I want to press
in these lectures is the intellectual
absurdity and political menace of trying
to grasp it of all political phenomena
on the basis of any such privilege but
what's the alternative indeed how can
anyone think of anything except from
their own point of view one of my
numerous drastically more distinguished
predecessors of Stimson lecturer the
late Samuel Huntington incurred a lot of
consumer Lee as well as coming in
to a handsome income stream for
insisting on another occasion that
civilizations have always clashed
throughout human history and were rather
evidently continuing to do so even today
the plentiful abuse heaped upon him was
distributed fairly evenly across the
presumed motives which led him to make
his claim the political damage which
critics saw his insistence are certain
to inflict and the intellectually
uncouth mode of thinking which they saw
with which they saw him as developing
his train of thought democracy's Odyssey
unprecedented in the history of human
for this speech is an object lesson in
how to register the weight of the
phenomena which Huntington invoked
without succumbing to either the
fatalism or the chauvinism which his
critics hastened to ascribe to him as
democracy at long last carries its
exhilarations and vulnerabilities
forward across the frontier which mez
preoccupied him the demographic or
political boundaries of the community of
Islam across the world it's easier to
see clearly what that passage does and
doesn't mean the inspirational surge of
democracy across that frontier has not
come from somewhere else it's been there
in bitter waiting and little if any hope
for a very long time the primal appeal
and force of democracy in the form in
which it has survived into the modern
world lies in the moment of rejection it
is when the people declare as they did
in the squares of Tunis and of Cairo
that what the people do not want is the
regime itself in those settings often
however discrepant the reasons that have
brought the challengers together and
however incompatible many of the
purposes they hope between them to
realize what becomes hypnotically
concrete is what they are to
to reject in that if in very little else
the purpose which brings them together
and the outcome they mean to achieve is
as focused as unitary and fleetingly
even a solitary as the political
purposes of very large numbers of people
ever guests for the present however
temporarily the option against the
regime is in the first place the option
for democracy because democracy in
vaguest outline is just the default
option either the regime or democracy or
chaos most people in downtown Cairo as
much as anywhere else want chaos least
of all apart from anything else most of
them live in it already almost none can
afford it except very briefly indeed so
either the regime or something
unmistakeably different and for the
present the name for the unmistakeably
different is democracy the political
form of whatever the people in due
course proved to want instead contrast
that with the picture of democracy's
arrival as it's natural for Americans to
see it and as some of them at least did
see it for a few years after 1989 in the
beginning said John Locke very long ago
espousing rather different ideological
agenda all the world was America more
than three centuries later for democracy
to have become the default option in
regime change seemed very briefly to
presage a striking global destination in
the end at least politically all the
world might become America America in
American in political tastes American in
its political habits and hence American
also in its ultimate of agencies but
that is scarcely what it ever could have
meant for democracy to cross any
frontier at all
very much like autocracy democracy is a
self indigenized in Category as it
crosses any frontier both by conceptual
necessity and by eminently practical
causality democracy takes on the
cowering of the population to which it
comes its boast is to reflect their
tastes and their choices and sooner or
later unless it's thrust back again and
expelled beyond the border reflect them
it will the politics of Gaza are
remarkably grim and of course they have
much to be grim about but for Hamas to
win its last election was not a
derogation from democracy it was what
democracy in all its dedicated
aberration of judgment at that point
imperatively required its easiest for
most of us to see the impediments to
mutual understanding when others are
attempting to understand us than when we
strain to understand them when Chinese
officials first attempted to take in the
nature of America's regime as Zhang
yuji's article makes clear the article I
referred to in the last lecture they
certainly didn't set out from the idea
of democracy instead they began with the
question of what lay at the apex of the
American state with the fact that
America lacked a monarch and had to make
do instead with a mere head man as the
governor-general of Yang Guang province
reported to the imperial court in 1817
in response to the opium smuggled in on
American ships these particular
barbarians have no monarch whatsoever
only ahead map the tribe publicly
selects several men who served in
succession according to the drawing of
lots for terms of four years of peace
commercial affairs are managed
independently by private individuals
you were not controlled or deputed by
the head man
this is a search process two decades
later in an unsigned article on the
United States of North America in the
missionary edited Eastern Western
monthly magazine the author reported
that the people rule the country
themselves and once every three years
elect a leader to manage governmental
affairs the following year a more
expansive article in the same periodical
reported once more that the Americans
did not set up a king as ruler of their
country instead they selected a
president vice president and other high
officials to serve for four-year terms
some improvement in targeting the
President must be attentive to the
people's wishes and have a deep
understanding of the arts of statecraft
so as to implement benevolent
governments thus the regulation of the
entire realm hinges on this single pivot
the chief executive exercised control
exercises control over his subordinate
officials and thereby regulates the
country's notables he keeps the various
affairs of government in order and
thereby pacifies the common people the
overall picture may have overlapped a
little with George Washington's but by
1838 it was a deeply Chinese vision of
what the American political process had
become deep in governmental affairs in
order from above by controlling
subordinate officials regulating the
notables and thus pacifying the common
people like the Emperor the president
was the pivot of the entire system and
as in China the key object was to pacify
the common people but what was already
clear in this article was that in
America the common people took much more
pacifying and maintained a far higher
degree of surveillance on their ruler
than was open to their Chinese
counterparts both advantages and
disadvantages of
these arrangements were soon recognized
even in China and the office of
president extricated from a vocabulary
commonly employed to pick out village
headmen Glanville captains or leaders of
bandit gangs and elevated to a more
suitably honorific status within half a
century interested chinese had left
behind them a degree of ignorance which
could assimilate presidential choice to
the outcome of a lottery a more
prejudicial verdict on the American
approach to ordering governmental
affairs than even Plato chose to pass on
the whimsical tea of Athenian political
choice
despite the ideological centrality of
random selection to the Athenian
practice of political equality by that
point
Chinese interpreters could readily
recognize the weight of public opinion
in shaping the agency of America's state
today plainly very large numbers of
China's population know vastly more
about America's recent political history
but the sheer imaginative difficulty of
holding up one set of political
arrangements against the other and
judging which looks best equipped to
realize the political goods you value
most highly hasn't noticeably lessened
for Chinese observers over time and the
prospective contribution of democracy is
still likely to feature as one element
in that puzzle than was a basis on which
it might be solved there's good reason
to believe that the gap between American
and Chinese visions of politics is wider
than most such gaps between very large
populations consciously aware of
inhabiting the same world at the same
time it's important to recognizing the
scale of that gap to see that the gap
itself isn't simply the product of
America's historical felicity and
China's until very recently relative
historical misfortune throughout most if
not all the historical exists
of the united states still less is it a
product of the exquisite political taste
with which that fortunate history has
endowed America's current citizens and
the miserably depleted political
imagination with which China's current
inhabitants for the most part have to
make do a more adequate way to see what
has produced it is to register two
things in the first place it's to take
in the vastly greater historical depth
of the Chinese vision and the consequent
difficulty of reshaping it decisively
unstable China's modern historians in
this country especially of lautner I'm
sure much more in China itself have long
shown in vivid and fascinating detail
just how hard it proved over the long
slow 19th century for China to let go of
dynastic monarchy as a form of
government without consciously
surrendering any sense of social value
or political meaning at all in the
second place it's to acknowledge how
miserably inadequate the West's
intellectual resources for understanding
politics have proved for China as it
struggled against the military and
technical superiority first of the
Western powers from there of Japan and
their cumulative ly disruptive
penetration of China's economy territory
and way of life even to concede the
superiority of a republic over a
dynastic monarchy was a very hard
stretch and as in the French case
initially opened to prompt
reconsideration finding a way in which a
republic could be relied on to cope with
military threat whether internal or
external proved impossible the
subordination of officials and the
regulation of notables were scarcely
even attempted and the implementation of
benevolent government lay all too
evident
beyond reach when later and more
ambitious offshoots of Western political
thinking arrived via Russia and was
suitably indigenized in their turn
China's luck scarcely improved the
economic experience recommended by
Russian advisers were not especially
successful and have since been abandoned
more or less in their entirety Chinese
improvisations in their place over three
decades didn't prove a clear improvement
and have mostly also since been
abandoned the record in subordinating
officials regulating notables and
furnishing benevolent government has
been more checkered and harder to read
but it remains hard to attribute it's
more discouraging elements to the
spurning of clear conceptions or
reliable experience of European
provenance for how to structure power or
hold it to benign purposes still less
ensure that its consequences would be
beneficial for the great majority of
China's population but of course
China's remarkable economic
transformation over the last three
decades hasn't been just a lucky
accident
neither China's long history nor the
cumulative intellectual acumen of the
West showed China's rulers how to do
what they have in fact done under
ferocious pressure and with remarkable
nerve and audacity they worked it out
for themselves they set and sustained a
framework in which scores of millions of
people reshaped an economic landscape at
breakneck speed and tilted the economy
of the world in new direction it's
anyone's guess how long that
transformation can go on with anything
like its current momentum or how far it
can ever hope to repair the collateral
damage its inflicted along the way but
it has occurred and it was the political
choices and exertions of the political
entity which rules China which made it
possible for
to do so that entity certainly has no
viable or compelling answer to the
question why it should be ruling China
or why it can reasonably be expected to
rule it beneficent Lee for the
foreseeable future
what it does have for the present is the
Mandate of Heaven in some respects which
its present leaders intermittently
acknowledge and others to which they
understandably prefer to turn a blind
eye it has definitely not been ruled at
all beneficent Lee but the people of
China need China to be ruled and like
the people of everywhere else they can't
at any particular moment pick and choose
the structures through which they are
being ruled or will be ruled in the near
future the one opportunity in that
respect which the people of America
evidently have in the people of China
conspicuously lacked is the opportunity
at regular intervals to pick many of the
personnel in the upper reaches of their
state the most strikingly of all to pick
the single individual at its apex
unlike the emperor who was picked at
least conceptually by superhuman forces
the people of America can pick their own
head man was it must sooner or later be
their own head woman for all the weight
of frustration and disappointment that
swirls around it that option still has
some imaginative centrality in American
understandings of democracy and still
retains its evanescent gratifications
what is gratifying about it isn't the
predictable benefit individual or
collective or the consequences of
exercising it it is the immediacy of
personal choice itself
there's no reason whatever to suppose
that China's citizens would not enjoy
exercising that choice as much as any
other citizens but there's nothing in
China's protracted prior history to give
them grounds to build
that exercising their choice will prove
a good recipe for ensuring that the head
man selected will shape China's state
agency for the best when they first
sought to fathom the American approach
in the 19th century George Washington
looked to some quite a good proxy for an
emperor but that was a very long time
ago and the vicissitudes of more recent
presidents do not and should not suggest
a comparable capacity to impart order to
America's turbulent political processes
leaving the choice of head man to the
discernment of the people is not a
strategy which instantly recommends
itself in Beijing it's not a natural
practical inference from China's
millennial political history or from the
intellectual history so closely impacted
upon it I've labored the last fight at
such length because the mutual political
comprehension of China's and Americans
within America's politically leaves
matters so intensely at present I want
now to turn to the challenge to mutual
political intelligibility posed by
another great Asian state the Republic
of India if there are any democracies in
the world today if the term democracy
isn't simply a misnomer when applied to
any extant state the Republic of India
is far the largest democracy there has
ever been it's also in some ways the
most surprising democracy has ever been
surprising in its scale and its
persistence amongst a huge and for the
myth for most of its existence
predominantly exceedingly poor
population and in its tensile strength
in face of fierce centrifugal pressure
and high levels of violence corruption
and human oppression throughout most of
its existence why is it still
there as a continuous legal political
organizational and civilization or
structure why does it still cover its
present territorial extension and
continue to hold the huge human
population which still lives upon that
territory why is it still valued so
highly by so many of its own citizens
miserably poor as much as Envy ibly
wealthy in face of levels of corruption
and criminality across its political
class which must be as high today as
they've ever been since the Republic's
founding and in face of levels of
violence deeply embedded in its social
economic and religious relations which
even six decades of purposefully
remedial constitutional rule in any
number of elaborate programs of legal
economic and social reform have largely
failed to pacify it's hard to exaggerate
the importance of the fact that it is
still there it's also hard to imagine
what doc democracy's future would look
like if the Republic of India had
continued to disintegrate in the wake of
the initial partition of Britain's
Indian Empire or even if the residue of
that Empire had in due course gone the
way of Pakistan the sheer fact of that
survival has shown two things very
clearly the extraordinary absorptive
capacity of democracy as a political
category and its severely limited
capacity to impose order on chaos and
pretty muted information even to attempt
to do anything of the kind
if there is inspiration in its
tumultuous journey as there unmistakably
is there's also at least equivalent
chastening high romance alongside very
grim realism the best way for the
present I think to see the balance
between the two soon optically is to
read attentively through
Ramachandra Guha wonderfully generous
and unconsented history India after
Gandhi one of the best political
histories of any country in the world
over the last 75 years what's made it
possible for India's Republic to last
for a full six decades is a number of
elements in its legacy from British
imperial rule and from the lengthy and
profound struggles to escape from that
rule the principal legacy from Imperial
rule itself was essentially common to
the two initial successor states but the
legacy from the struggles against it was
distributed all together less
symmetrically
it's tempting accordingly especially for
Indians to attribute the divergence in
democracy's fortunes in those two states
to the weaker and less edifying
political resources of jinnah's Muslim
League and the cumulative nationalist
achievement of the Congress party and
it's great leaders especially in their
very different ways to Mohandas Gandhi
Jawaharlal Nehru and valiber Patel the
record of India's subsequent political
leaders has been both more checkered and
more ordinary though it's certainly
encompassed at intervals very
considerable personal achievements at
least one of them for better and for
worse was a very notable political
leader indeed but what stands out with
the benefit of hindsight is how
singularly fortunate India's Republic
was in its founders in the imaginative
scale and intensity which Gandhi had
given to the quest for nationhood across
so many hundreds of millions of people
before nationhood was won the vision
patience and political courage of Nehru
in defining sulfur in nationhood as he
went along and the massive political
realism and good sense of Patel when the
time came to assume it it was a great
political feat to turn the scruffy
palimpsest of M
into a cohesive territorial state in
relatively steady control over most of
its subsequent history of borders which
were often intensely vulnerable both
from the outside and from within it was
a great political feat to recreate a
semblance of civic order across most of
that territory
through the grim and bloody aftermath of
partition and recompose it time and
again in face of decades of bitter
economic caste and communal conflict in
an endless variety of settings there was
no overriding reason why India should
not have split and re split endlessly
through one secession after another as
may yet happen with Pakistan and began
to do so decades ago with the creation
of Bangladesh the reason why India
didn't go that way is not well focused
even today it's in part certainly a
consequence of the scale and character
of the Indian Army and the pride it's
contrived to sustain in face of pressing
personal temptations in placing the
constitutional integrity of the state
above the gratification of individual
ambition and corporate self advancement
it's in part a product of the prodigious
administrative reach of the Indian state
for all its bureaucratic clumsiness and
rigidity and its fluctuating commitment
to legal responsibilities a reach most
evocatively shown in the stunning
complexity and punctilious Ness of its
electoral rituals and the unique
political standing of their emblematic
institution the Electoral Commission of
India it's certainly in part also a
product of the depth of thought through
political construction
embodied in its Constitution making and
the stamp which that placed on the
continuing project of a rule of law
which might readily have been vitiating
irretrievably by its Imperial provenance
or by cynical deflection into the
subsequent convenience of a varyingly
beleaguered or appropriative executive
within the frame of India's Republic
those resources have to a striking
degree worked together and not as they
quite readily might have done and have
necessarily in fact done from time to
time worked more or less lethally
against one another there have been
times of great peril in enabling them to
do so
notably the period of Indira Gandhi's
emergency but also with partition right
at the beginning were currently with
Jammu and Kashmir with the traumas of
Amritsar the poison flooding out from
Ayodhya and the endless miseries of
Bihar and the hapless rural backgrounds
which have subsequently succeeded to its
mantle
you can also question the felicity of
their consequences ask how far they have
worked to the net benefit of a very
large proportion of India's population
at any point in its history and also
question equally as you can in any
capitalist democracy how far such
benefits as of a group from there
working for that huge population have
been augmented or depleted by the
operations more specifically of India's
democratic institutions if the latter
had worked very substantially worse it's
reasonable to assume that that would
have greatly impaired the appeal of
those institutions and no doubt of their
consequences for the wealth and standard
of living of a fair majority had been
very much handsomer that too would have
been gracious it democracy as a
political principle more urgently to
more of India citizens but if you tried
to trace out systematically how those
consequences have in fact accrued their
net impact is still hard to read since
its Athenian heyday democracy has had
more Flair and animus when it comes to
distribution than when it comes to
production
some of the distributive gains of the
conspicuously badly off in given
settings have been traceable
unequivocally to the Democratic
bargaining within Indian political
institutions and to explicitly
articulated rectification purposes in
those respects it's hard to see how
democratic institutions could vindicate
themselves more conclusively the long
slow struggle to offset the accumulated
historical oppression of the lower
castes Untouchables and tribals with the
spiritual authority of Gandhi behind it
and the shaping impact of BR Ambedkar
both in the drafting of the Constitution
itself and throughout his long political
career certainly generated anomalies
have its own along the way but it too
has been a series and a burnable a
project of rectifying a vast historical
injustice this human history
conclusively point to innit to democracy
has carried a large proportion of the
burden and if it's scarcely to India's
creditors of civilizational site still
less with the prejudice of the British
Empire that the New Republic inherited
so much to rectify it's hard to think of
an attributable outcome of democracy in
operation which is so unequivocally to
its credit for all the often deeply
unpleasant cautionary tales which
disfigure it the record of India's
democracy as a ho forms a single giant
political achievement and one which has
already has an immense impact on the
political imaginations of other
countries and may yet have very much
more if we press the question of why
that achievement has been affected
besides the historical legacies which
made it possible and the wide range of
political actions through which it was
reached and secured there's something
else left over which is central to the
theme I've been trying to explore the
special Indian in game
with democracy as a category and the
wealth and heterogeneity of the
potential which Indians have initiated
from their romance with that category
and their explorations of it that should
be a theme with a special resonance for
an American audience both for the
opportunity it offers for widening
imaginative sympathy and for the
instructive complement it provides to
America's own very rather different
romance with an expiration of the
category the Indian Tara's yet has been
told more fruitfully and less
illuminating Lee than the American for
somewhat different reasons but this
protracted in order bility from the
outside and in part I think even within
India itself is beginning at last to
come to an end and the story of India's
political thinking from the 20th century
onwards is now being termed with
increasing confidence and intimacy as a
cumulative record of political
experience and even political learning
it's yet to be joined convincingly to an
understanding of India's long
intellectual past the cumulative riches
especially of classical Sanskrit
learning and the proliferation of
vernaculars across the subcontinent
but joined in due course it is going to
be and when it is there's no reason why
India's dramatic political experience
should look or feel any less coherent
than the political experience of America
or France Britain or Germany Japan or
dare one say it China itself and India's
political experience whatever will be
true by then for Japan or China or
indeed Germany or Britain neither of
whose experiences after all still
appears especially exemplary democracy
is certainly still going to be the
master category it isn't just that
India's national elections
each time they occur
are always the biggest democratic
elections there have ever be it's also
that democracy's adventure in India is
still the greatest adventure on which
that endlessly untransparent category
has yet to launch itself you can see
that adventure from several different
angles at a minimum intellectual
organizational heuristic and coercive to
do it any justice you must at least try
to see it each of those ways and then
put the different trajectories across
each of them together especially you
must do so if you hope to extricate your
own understanding of democracy from the
necessarily parochial framing in which
you'll inevitably have formed it on the
Indian subcontinent and since
independence particularly in India
itself more women and men have peered
into democracy's mirror and strained to
take in what they see than have done so
anywhere else
true initially they did so on a more
modest scale than the immigrant
population of this country has chosen to
ever the last two or three centuries I
doubt if the term democracy can be
shared to have reached India before the
18th century at the earliest that might
be true about me but it remains a very
deep question how far the idea and
practice of democracy had featured in
the texture of Indian society and the
workings of Indian imaginations as far
back as or even further than it can
plausibly be seen to appear in any
European society just how that
immemorial
if shadowy presence was to relate to
inform and constrain India's destiny and
capabilities as an independent state was
a central issue of judgment and
allegiance for the nationalist movement
from quite early in the 20th century it
very much remained such however
confusedly as for society as a whole
faces the future today
you can think of the presence of
democracy in India simply as the current
form of its state but you can also think
of it and may do so with greater
sympathy as many Indians emphatically do
as the defuse set of practices
elaborately dispersed across the social
landscape which make up India's civil
society with all levels from villages to
political or commercial capitals
endlessly reinserting itself between
government and individual citizen and
tussling away to soften coercive impacts
on those worst place to defend
themselves and boy up the facilities to
support those most abject ly in need as
well undoubtedly was pursuing a
prodigious variety of other and rather
less edifying girls it's easy for the
denizens of each of those settings
rulers and activists alike to view their
mutual relations in zero-sum terms as a
ceaseless struggle for dominance but it
defies the sense of democracy either as
a term or as an idea to see their
relation that way in each setting and
from each angle the demos those who
fondly identify themselves with the
interest with its interest and so with
it the demos judge or act as best they
can on its behalf and with its
presumptive Authority if you disapprove
of what they choose to do you're
unlikely to view that more charitably
because of the authority they invoke but
whatever facilities it may offer for
self-deception
and whatever abuses it can cynically be
put to you can't reasonably deny that
the category of democracy is open to
both interpretations and that something
of normative and political significance
and value is captured in each to miss
supply a political category is never to
invalidate it there are no political
concepts or
is capable of carrying validity which
can't also be more or less gracefully
miss applied one of the lessons we most
urgently need to learn about democracy
is how readily and unresistingly it can
be miss applied and how practically
contradictory even perfectly defensible
applications of it can readily prove
that's the simple intuition which my
which my overall title is aimed as well
as the covered theme much of this
lecture I hope you're beginning to pick
up the plotline if you look at
democracy's adventure in India as a
highly populated passage of intellectual
history there are several different
sequences to which you would have to
attend an increasingly crowded canvas as
you move towards the present and try to
peer forward beyond it
two of those sequences can be traced in
exemplary fashion in the work of one of
your present teachers Karina Montana and
especially in her superb book alibis of
empire the first the inherent
contradictions of liberal imperialism
was at first an Occidental intrusion and
aspiring remedy for the blatantly
untoward profile of unapologetically pre
liberal imperialism the long shadow of
Warren Hastings or at least the specter
of his rule passed on by Edmund Burke to
Britain's political class whom liberal
imperialism that all points was a
project rather than a plausible
historical description of governmental
practice imperial rule as a favour for
those at the receiving end humanitarian
intervention for the very long haul its
titanic exponent John Stuart Mill
classic theorist of democracy as
collective self education for those he
teamed up to it firmly denied its
applicability to pre harbor Marcion
social time Poorna smith himself put it
any state of things anterior to the time
man
have become capable of being improved by
free and equal discussion he pre
Harbormaster and of course wasn't Mills
phraseology but I think you'll agree
that that is actually a correct labeling
he based his analysis firmly on the
contrast between civilization and
barbarism with the former defined by
human beings acting together for common
purposes in large bodies and fully
capable of reciprocation and hence of
rule following the latter briskly
inverting the assessment and hence
requiring direct subjection by the more
advanced Mill himself was serenely
confident in the quality he was an
intellectual and political judgment
seeing the main point of superiority in
the political theories of the present as
their acceptance that the institutions
through which a population is ruled need
to be radically different according to
the stage of advancement already reached
and taking his view from his own
father's precept that knave scheme of
government can happily conduce to the
end of government unless it's adapted to
the state of the people for whose usage
is intended it's easier today to sneer
at Mills complacency over the Imperial
element in the ways he and his father
chose to spend their lives it's hard to
not to enjoy his merciless pillar iing
by James Fitz Taran for the vision of
britain's indian empire is based on a
moral duty on the part of the English
nation to try to educate the natives in
such a way as to lead them to set up a
democratic form of government
administered by representative
institutions and Stephens challenge why
what was good enough for Charlemagne and
Akbar in their emphatically coercive
dealings with backward states of society
shouldn't carry through to the relations
between the educated and the uneducated
back in Britain itself but it's
dangerous to sneer too readily
we've scarcely left the dilemmas of
liberal
imperialism comfortably behind us and if
we shrink from employing the criterion
of advancement explicitly any longer we
die early need a less condescending
prophecy for it's strictly pragmatic
counterpart what clear and reliable
advances have we yet made in discerning
how to enable failed states to succeed
or to induce states without either
capacity or inclination to civilize
their subjects to said about the arduous
struggle to do so how much more robustly
directive is our own theory of how to
civilize the world than Mills has proved
to be it's especially important to
register that question since however
haphazardly and in the teeth of Stephens
smear there's a clear sense in which by
independence britain's indian
administrators had at least enabled
enough indians to educate themselves in
such a way has led them to set up
precisely a democratic form of
government administered by
representative institutions that form of
government is still there today
and it was the clear choice in the end
of the main strand in india's
nationalist movement that it should be
and they made that choice through very
extensive argument and often bitter
conflict over quite a long time that is
the third of the sequences you would
need to trace as intellectual history to
grasp the full impact of democracy on
india as i've already tried to suggest
it's also proved the most momentous even
with the privilege of hindsight that
option still comes out as India's
largest strictly political resource in
establishing and sustaining the most
astonishing democracy there has yet be
it's the second sequence on which
Kareena Manson has concentrated most of
her work so far
she begins from a deep intellectual
reaction to Mills viewpoint prompted in
large part by
may that the evident fragility of
imperial rule in the wake of the 1857
uprising a favored flamboyantly
unrecognized the search by its
recipients the reaction pivoted on the
intellectual work of Sir Henry Maine who
recast the vice-regal image of India and
helped to transform much of the
sophisticated European sense of what a
society really consists in by doing so
he focused on India's innumerable
villages and the complex practices which
sustained them saw in their beleaguered
residual autonomy a balance between
promise and danger and set out to try to
guide his imperial colleagues in the
formidable assignment of shoring up the
promise and controlling the danger
movingly and the reasons we still do not
clearly understand Maine's remarkable
reorientation of the imperial mind set
up intricate resonances between European
and in due course American efforts to
rethink the modern state as an intricate
and gratuitously overconfident pseudo
totality in necessarily and deservedly
limited control of a burgeoning array of
sub state institutions many of which
have long preceded it and had distinctly
better prospects of operation coherently
from the point of view of their human
participants to European wing of that
movement of thought gloried ISM did not
itself for the most part set out from
Maine it came and then very largely went
over a few decades though it's recently
began to seep back its American wing
never encountered the same level of
resistance from admirers or would-be
deployers of the state and has remained
a fairly steady presence divided but in
India itself in quite direct response to
Mae
and many of the realities of Indian
society it figured dramatically in
shaping the Swadeshi element in the
nationalist movement inspired a highly
distinctive vision of India's realities
and possibilities centered on tilting
power initiative and social Hope back
from state centers towards the villages
and generated some of the most striking
imaginative moments in India's modern
intellectual history from Ramachandra
mukajee's look Lucknow school of
sociology and his 1921 study in
comparative politics democracies of the
east to the mesmerizing figure of
Mohandas Gandhi and the great champions
of India's indefatigably still
burgeoning civil society from 1949 after
today it also joined India's politics to
the intricacies of its enduring
religious heritage more richly and
promising Lee than the legions of
electoral politicians who have since
traded on the claim to do so since the
spoils of office came within reach it
cannot be said that that remarkable
inspiration has ever achieved a tight
grip on the performance of its
inveterate and often immediate enemy the
Indian state but that was a victory
plainly precluded from the start if it
scarcely facing a kind of ecology in the
near future as India's growth rate
accelerates at last and her leading
capitalists loom ever larger and perhaps
ever less scrupulous it's also by now
clear that the presence it has assumed
across India and society is too dense
and pervasive for there to be any chance
that its voice will simply die away the
scale of democracy's impact on India
raises pressing questions both for
Indians themselves and for the rest of
the world's inhabitants for Indians the
most important judgement is how on
balance the impact has come out for the
rest of us the key question is what it
shows about
the political properties of democracy as
a category and its capacity to survive
and reach itself in different settings
and then direct the political energies
of their inhabitants for the better we
can judge the answers to both questions
best by pressing the question of what
democracy has done for the Indians the
criteria here aren't elusive how far has
it ages and impeded them in their
individual and collective quests for
wealth and power how successfully has it
reconciled a society in which every
adult member is deemed fully fit to
judge an act politically for themselves
- and with the dizzying injustice of so
much of its own past or ageing it to
recompose its two tech hierarchies of
caste and brutal chasms of class into a
community of real equals how far in
addressing each of those exacting and
arguably fantastical girls as it
equipped the citizens of India to
recognize and respond to their ever more
pressing need to preserve and restore a
viable habitat in which to do so how
safely and securely has it woven those
tasks together said that none disappears
from sight or suffers irreparably from
prioritizing the others by those
standards has Indian democracy proved a
good idea or has it proved a strikingly
bad one that's the night on which I
meant to end but there's one thought now
I'd like to add one which bears on
Karuna mountainous conference on ends
and means this Friday if you answer the
question of how far India's democracy
has been a good idea by applying to
India as it is today the criterion of
liberal cosmopolitan right you will have
to concede that Indian democracy has
proved a fairly complete flop but if you
ask what
had the same result you apply to the
United States incidentally but if you
ask what would be needed to be done
politically and indeed militarily to
turn the Indian parents s that
independence into a normative tabula
rasa
undisguised to cosmopolitan liberal
taste you would have to recognize the
ferocity and the utter abandonment of
inhibition needed to carry through that
vast and giddy transformation fear all
ends in politics dictate their own means
and no means in politics are either
liberal or democratic independently of
what can be done and of what the
consequences of doing it will prove to
be democracy in India has not proved an
especially liberal idea but what it has
proved in active political use over time
is a strikingly democratic